[Musik]
mit fast 10 Millionen Einwohnern und
einer Fläche von rund 200.000
Quadratkilometern ist der Protagonist
unseres heutigen Videos ein Land das in
letzter Zeit vor allem aus drei Gründen
aufgefallen ist erstens weil es also
nichts Geringeres als die letzte
Diktatur Europas gilt die Diktatur
russland hat sich ja bewusst aus dem
europäischen Kreis verabschiedet
zweitens weil es eine Schlüsselrolle bei
der russischen Invasion in der Ukraine
gespielt hat und weiterhin spielt und
drittens weil es sich um den einzigen
offiziellen europäischen Verbündeten von
Vladimir Putins Russland handelt wenn
man mal von
opportunistischen Maulwürfen wie Viktor
Barbara abzieht die Rede ist natürlich
von Alexander lukaschen Weißrussland
überlegt doch mal nie zuvor hatte dieses
Land eine so wichtige Rolle gespielt wie
jetzt und nein es geht nicht darum dass
ich locker Schenker als der Retter
Putins aufspielte als Erwachsener
bossbrik OS schon von seinem Marsch auf
Moskau abbrachte nein Belarus ist auch
der Ort an dem die russische Invasion
der Ukraine am 24 Februar 2022 begann
vergesst bitte nicht dass die erste
russische Offensive von der
weißrussischen Region Hommel ausgehen
und das war noch nicht alles parallel
sofortmaß der Bodentruppen startete die
russischen Luftwaffe Dutzende von
Angriffen auf ukrainische Ziele mit
Flugzeugen und Raketen die ebenfalls von
Weißrussland ausstatteten
historischer versprechen dass die
Ukraine niemals von seinem Land aus
angegriffen werden würde spielte
Weißrussland in Putins Plänen Kiew
innerhalb von 72 Stunden zu erobern eine
absolute Schlüsselrolle an diejenigen
die uns Vorwürfe machen musstet ihr
nicht dass wir das engste Bündnis mit
der Russischen Föderation haben mit
ihnen bauen wir einen einzigen mächtigen
und unabhängigen Start auf den
Unionsstaat wir waren und werden mit dem
brüderlichen Russland zusammen sein
unser Teilnahme an der spezialoperation
von mir schon vor langer Zeit
beschlossen Alexander Präsident von
Belarus seitdem ist das Land mit Abstand
am stärksten von den internationalen
Sanktionen betroffen sowohl
wirtschaftlich als auch politisch einige
der bekanntesten Unternehmen des Landes
haben sogar beschlossen das Land zu
verlassen zum Beispiel war Gaming der
Entwickler von bekannten Spielen wie
diesen hier
Weißrusslands größte spieleunternehmen
verlässt das Land und Russland World of
Tanks Entwickler
die Studios und verlagert Betrieb der
Spiele aber wisst ihr was das ist noch
nicht einmal das Schlimmste das
schlimmste ist das nun lange Zeit nach
Beginn des Krieges nicht mehr nur die
Souveränität der Ukraine sondern auch
die von Weißrussland selbst in Gefahr
ist ja ganz genau dieses Land könnte ihn
nicht allzu ferner Zukunft verschwinden
und zwar nicht gerade durch einen
einmalstellung Ukraine oder der NATO
Weißrussland läuft Gefahr vom großen
russischen Bären annektiert zu werden
und nein nicht nur das ukrainische
Parlament ist der Meinung dass Russland
Belarus de facto bereits besetzt hat
diese Position vertritt auch die
wählerische Opposition die fast komplett
vom Diktator ins Exil vertrieben oder
inhaftiert worden ist und das alles hat
uns beide so alt Politik veranlasst ein
paar Fragen zu stellen läuft Bella raus
wirklich Gefahr von Russland eine Tier
zu werden wieso hängt dies eng mit dem
Verlauf des russischen Krieges in der
Ukraine zusammen was genau steckt hinter
den angeblichen Absichten moskauz und
warum scheint Lukaschenka nichts dagegen
zu unternehmen in diesem Video werden
wir natürlich all diese wichtigen Fragen
beantworten lasst mich euch aber vorher
eine andere wichtige Frage stellen
hättet ihr Lust noch bis Ende September
einfach mal so ganz schnell
155 Euro vom Finanzamt zu bekommen dann
hört mal gut zu denn Ende September
endet die steuerfrist für das Jahr 2022
und praktischerweise wird das heutige
Video von Steuerbord gesponsert eine
äußerst praktischen App mit der ihr eure
Steuererklärung ganz easy am Handy in 20
Minuten machen könnt denn wusstest du
dass viele deutsche Steuerzahler jedes
Jahr viel Geld verschenken nur weil sie
die komplexe steuerbürokratie absteigt
dabei würde es sich durchaus lohnen sich
mal zu überwinden schließlich haben laut
Statistischen Bundesamt im vergangenen
Jahr 12,3 Millionen Menschen eine
Steuererstattung bekommen und zwar im
Schnitt eben jene 1.95 Euro und mit
Steuerbord muss man sich kein bisschen
über finden um die Steuererstattung
einstreichen zu können Steuerbord ist
quasi so etwas wie Jetski BT mit einem
steuerberatungs Plugin das während es
mit ihr plaudert im Hintergrund schon
mal deine Steuererklärung ausfüllt und
optimiert und innerhalb von nur 20
Minuten ist deine Steuererklärung fertig
und zu Übermittlung ans Finanzamt bereit
komplett papierlos und digital sollte es
notwendig sein unterstützt dich auch der
fachkundige menschliche Support
jederzeit mit garantierten Antwort
Zeiten innerhalb von 24 Stunden alles
was du brauchst ist deine
Lohnsteuerbescheinigung und schon kannst
du losgehen klick einfach auf den Link
in der Videobeschreibung oder geh über
den QR-Code den Base einblenden denn
damit erhältst du sogar noch 10 € Rabatt
übrigens sollte die Steuererstattung
unter 50 € liegen berechne die
Steuerbord keinerlei Gebühren und ist
dann komplett kostenlos also schenkt den
starten nicht euer sauer verdientes Geld
und klickt jetzt auf den Link in der
Videobeschreibung oder skanding QR-Code
und bis Ende September noch weitere 10 €
Rabatt zu bekommen tut einem Geldbeutel
doch mal etwas Gutes und fange jetzt
gleich an so einfach Ste uern zu sparen
wie nie zuvor mit Steuerbord vielleicht
kommt dabei ja genug herum dass du damit
auch unsere Arbeit finanziell
unterstützen kannst den Spenden Link
dazu findest du übrigens ebenfalls in
der Beschreibung unter dem Video so und
wenn ihr das alles erledigt habt dann
lasst uns sofort untersuchen was da
eigentlich in Belarus gerade vor sich
geht aufgepasst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine Lieben visualpolitik Zuschauer im
Grunde hat Weißrussland ein großes
Problem außer Moskauer Sicht handelt es
sich weder um einen wirklich anderes
fremdes noch ein völlig unabhängiges
Land stattdessen sehen Sie es als eine
Art autonomes Gebiet das eigentlich fest
zu einem erträumten groß Russland gehört
und wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt ist
das natürlich äußerst beunruhigend wenn
ihr die Hintergründe diese Imperial
nationalistischen Vision kennt wir haben
über sie schon mehrere Videos gedreht
und ich werde sie euch verlinken aber
das schlimmste ist dass dies keine
ausschließlich russische Perspektive ist
als Lukaschenka 1994 an die Macht kam
gewann er die Wahl durch eine Kampagne
die vor allem auf eine Integration mit
Russland berote vor allem im
wirtschaftlichen Bereich aber nicht nur
in diesem sagen wir mal Luca Schenker
erhielt damals politische und
wirtschaftliche Unterstützung aus Moskau
hingegenzug für die propagation des
russischen Weltbildes in Belarus
tatsächlich basiert die weißrussische
Identität die jahrelang vom Regime
gefördert wurde und weiterhin gefördert
wird vor allem auf dem Kult der
sowjetischen Vergangenheit auf dem
Großen Vaterländischen Krieg den Zweiten
Weltkrieg und der brüderlichen
Verbundenheit mit Russland über den Rest
der weißrussischen Vergangenheit hört
man keinen Pieps sechs Jahrhunderte der
eigenen und eigenständigen Geschichte
werden einfach ausgeblendet weil sie
nicht ins narrativ der macht aber in
minskultur Moskau passen lukaschen
selbst hat im staatlichen Fernsehen
gesagt dass die weißen im Grunde
genommen großen mit einem
Qualitätssiegel sind tatsächlich wahr
ist zum großen Teil diese Position die
erklärt warum Moskau und mindestens 1999
einen bilateralen Vertrag
unterzeichneten um schrittweise den
sogenannten unionstaat zu bilden mit
anderen Worten die beiden Länder haben
beschlossen zu fusionieren um ihre
gesellschaftliche politische und
wirtschaftliche Integration mit
gemeinsamen Institutionen bis zum
Äußersten zu verst wir reden zum
Beispiel über eine gemeinsame Währung
und ein einheitliches Steuerrecht
[Musik]
so weit ist es zwar noch nicht gekommen
aber von Anfang an wurden die
Freizügigkeit zwischen den beiden
Ländern und die Vereinheitlichung der
beiden Arbeitsmärkten festgelegt wir
Russen die weißrösten brauchen also
weder eine Genehmigung noch andere
besondere Dokumente um in dem anderen
der beiden Länder zu arbeiten aber alles
in allem müssen wir uns die Frage
stellen warum sich Weißrussland zu
diesen wichtigen Schritt entschlossen
hat immerhin scheint doch ein großes
Risiko zu bestehen einfach untergebutter
zu werden oder ich meine ein kleines
Land das sich mit einem viel größeren
Land verbundenet gab vereint da ist es
doch klar dass am Ende wieder mal alle
Entscheidungen in Moskau getroffen
werden oder nun eigentlich nicht
zumindest ist es nicht das was Luca
Schenker im Sinn hatte
der Bauer schlaue Taktierer schmiedet
damals ganz andere Pläne die 1990er
Jahre waren von Russland eine sehr
schwere Zeit das Land befand sich in
einer ständigen Krise und das weckte den
Ehrgeiz des weißrussischen Führers die
wir euch von mehreren früheren Videos
erläutert haben kam lukaschen zu
Überzeugung dass in vielen gemeinsamen
Gremien das Gewicht der Macht von
Russland und Weißrussland genau gleich
groß sein würde er ging sogar so weit zu
glauben dass er selbst diese Art von
Supra statt anführen könnte in seiner
Vorstellung würde der agile schwanzloka
schenka mit dem lahmenden Datteln
wackeln im Laufe der Zeit sahen die
Dinge natürlich ganz anders aus so dass
wir aus weißrussischer Perspektive heute
nicht mehr von einer Partnerschaft
sprechen sondern von einer realen Gefahr
eines Anschlusses an Russland
und die Frage ist war lukaschenker
wirklich so naiv wie konnte der letzte
Diktator Europas so leicht überlistet
werden nun die Wahrheit ist dass dies
überhaupt nicht so leicht war der
russische Diktator balancierte sehr
lange immer zwischen Russland und Europa
hielt sich alle Optionen offen er legte
sich im Laufe der Jahre sogar öfters mit
dem Kreml an bis ja bis die Lage eines
Tages vollkommen auf eine Seite kippte
was ist also passiert das mindest
praktisch vor Moskau kapituliert hat ja
genau das nehmen wir jetzt genau unter
die Lupe aufgepasst
kalkulierte Zweideutigkeit
schon kurz nach der Unterzeichnung des
unionsvertrags begann der rohstoff- und
Öl superzyklus der Putins erste Amtszeit
an der Spitze Russlands beflügelte in
diesen ersten Jahren flossen Dollars
nach Russland als gäbe es kein Morgen
und natürlich profitierte auch
Weißrussland von dieser plötzlichen
Welle des Wohlstands die Exporte des
kleinen Nachbarin ins Russische
Riesenreich schossen in die Höhe viele
junge Menschen zogen ins Nachbarland um
dort zu arbeiten und natürlich
vervielfachten sich die direkt
Investitionen russische Unternehmen im
Land dies waren die goldenen Jahre von
Luca schenkas Belarus aber wie das
Sprichwort schon sagt war nicht alles
Gold was glänzte es gab ein Probleme ein
großes Problem das den weißrussischen
Diktator nachts wach hielt schon bald
nach Putin es macht Übernahme war
lukaschenker klar dass der neue
russische Staatschef nicht wie jenzin
war und das luki's Pläne den gemeinsamen
Staat auf dessen Gründung sie sich
geeinigt hatten selbst zu steuern zum
Scheitern verurteilt waren
[Applaus]
infolgedessen besang man sich in mensk
auf eine Hinhaltetaktik plötzlich hatte
man es überhaupt nicht mehr eilig mit
der brüderlichen Vereinigung man kann
das unionsprojekt zu verzögern gar zu
sabotieren und nicht nur das als die
Ölpreise wieder sanken und die russische
Wirtschaft so schwächeln begann nutzte
die belarussische Regierung die
Gelegenheit um sich von Moskau
unabhängiger zu machen man fängt an nach
dem Westen zu blicken das Ziel bei der
riesige Markt der Europäischen Union
[Musik]
und das ist noch nicht alles die
regiepropaganda begann auch eine eigene
nationale Identität zu entwickeln die
über den russischen Zentralismus
hinausgehen so warfen 2014 mehrere
russische Medien den Fehler russische
staatsche vor mit dem Nationalismus zu
liebäugel unsere versuchen die russische
Kultur zu verdrängen es gibt eine
unerklärte russophobe Kampagne in
Weißrussland und nationalistische Kräfte
werden offen unterstützt Juri Baran
schickt ein Pro russischer
politkommentator im Jahr 2014 die
Regierung ergriff heimlich alle
möglichen Maßnahmen einige davon suchst
symbolisch wie das Ersetzen von St
Georgs Bändern die bei Bayern verbreitet
sind durch die grünen roten
Nationalfarben Weißrusslands außerdem
gegen das Regime 2018 so weit dass es
zuvor verbundene öffentliche Feiern zum
Jahrestag der weiße russischen Republik
die 1918 nach der vorübergehen
Abspaltung von Russland ausgerufen wurde
nicht nur erlaubte sondern sogar zu
ihnen aufrief bei der Ausrufung der
weißrussischen Republik im Jahr 19
handelt es sich um den ersten Versuch
einer nationalen
Unabhängigkeitserklärung in der modernen
Geschichte der Weißrussen
[Musik]
wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt handelt es
sich um ein extrem starkes Symbol
Belarussisch nationalistischer
Bewegungen aber das sind nur zwei
Beispiele für eine Bewegung die zum
ersten Mal eindeutig eine echte
nationale Identität stärken wollte es
überrascht nicht dass das belarussische
Regime zu diesem Zeitpunkt bereits viel
vorsichtiger gegenüber Putins neue
Russland geworden war sie trauten ihn
nicht und ahnten dass das Land früher
oder später von Russland geschluckt
werden würde wenn sie nicht eine klare
nationale Identität festigen und nach
kommerziellen und wirtschaftlichen
Alternativen suchen sollen sie waren
sogar bereit im Gegenzug für mehr
wirtschaftliche und politische
Unabhängigkeit auch bestimmte russische
Subventionen zu verzichten ja damals
waren die Beziehungen zwischen Minsk und
Moskau nicht gerade die besten Anfang
2020 ging Russland sogar so weit das ist
eine Öllieferungen nach Weißrussland
unterbrach und die Grenzkontrollen für
die Personenverkehr wieder einführte und
der russische Energie Kriege gegen
Belarus 2020 war sogar schon der dritte
denn bereits 2004 hatte Moskau versucht
ist Russland durch das zudrehen des
gashandsgefüge zu machen und dann 2007
noch einmal um euch ein Vorstellung
davon zu geben wie die Dinge standen
Lukaschenka weigerte sich eigentlich die
ganze Zeit über die russische Annexion
der Krim anzuerkennen für ihn war die
Ukraine nach wie vor ein fester
Bestandteil der Ukraine und er machte
sogar aussagen wie diese Belarus würde
niemals zulassen dass andere Länder
unser Territorium für eine militärische
Intervention in der Ukraine nutzen
Alexander Lukaschenka 2017 das Problem
ist das eine Annäherung an den Westen
manchmal leichter gesagt als getan ist
vor allem wenn ihr eine Diktatur mit
eiserner Faust und einer furchtbar
veralteten Wirtschaft seid im Falle
Weißrussland konnte das Land nur
Rohstoffe und Produkte mit geringer
Wertschöpfung in die Europäische Union
exportieren Holz Metall Kartoffeln und
vor allem pedrochemische Produkte
Weißrussland verfügt nämlich über eine
riesige installierte Raffineriekapazität
zur Produktion von Kraftstoffen und
Erdöl Derivaten und jetzt werdet ihr
euch sicher fragen wo liegt das Problem
nun diese gesamte Industrie die größte
des Landes hängt im wesentlichen von der
Versorgung mit billigen russischen Erdöl
ab während es also seine Exporte in den
besten steigerte erhöhte es gleichzeitig
seine Abhängigkeit von Russland es
handelt es sich wahrlich um keine
einfache Situation aber die Wahrheit war
auf jeden Fall dass die Entfernung
zwischen Moskau und Minsk immer größer
wurde man könnte sagen es gab damals die
große Chance Weißrussland einfach
allemal den Einflussbereich des Krems zu
entreißen und dennoch meine Lieben
besorgenpolitik Zuschauer brachte dieser
Prozess im Jahr 2020 plötzlich zusammen
und nein es lag nicht an dem was ihr
jetzt denkt das entscheidende Ereignis
in dieser ganzen Geschichte war nicht
sondern die Präsidentschaftswahl
am 9 August 2020 fanden die
Präsidentschaftswahlen statt und Luca
Schenker erhielt dabei offiziell knapp
über 80% der Stimmen natürlich waren
diese Wahlen so manipuliert wie ein
Eishockeyspiel gegen Putin oder ein
leichtathletik-rennen gegen Kim Jong-un
der springende Punkt war jedoch dass
dieses skandalöse Ergebnis riesige
Proteste im Land ausgelöst hat
friedliche Proteste die einen
kurzwechsel forderten diese waren jedoch
so groß und hatten so viel international
Unterstützung dass das belarussische
Regime zum ersten Mal ins Wanken gerät
und das war noch nicht alles zu allem
Überfluss begannen die weißrösten
massenhaft Geld von den Banken abzuheben
und versuchten mit allen Mitteln ihre
belarussischen Hobel in stärkere
Währungen wie den Dollar oder den Euro
umzutauschen für den Fall dass etwas
passieren sollte innerhalb eines Monats
hatten die Bürger des Landes die
Reserven der Zentralbank praktisch
aufgebraucht und Institutionen wieder
IWF wollten nicht helfen wenn sie
wollten natürlich nicht mit dem Geld
ihrer Mitglieder einen Diktator an der
Macht halten das Land stand also am
Rande des Zusammenbruchs und lukaschen
Diktatur schien am seinen Faden zu
hängen es gab nur einen Ausweg er musste
sich in die Arme Russland stürzen
und wisst ihr was putin hatte auf diese
Gelegenheit schon viele Jahre gewartet
das weißrussische Regime im Bad den
Kreml Machthaber um Hilfe und innerhalb
nur wenige Tage bewilligte Russland ein
erstes Rettungspaket in Höhe von 1,5
Milliarden Dollar und zusammen mit
diesem finanziellen Rettungspaket war
sprach Russland auch militärische
Unterstützung 16 August 2020 wladimir
Putin hat angeboten den weißrussischen
Präsidenten Alexander Lukaschenko am
militärisch zu unterstützen während sich
bis zu 200.000 Demonstranten versammeln
um seine Absetzung zu fördern darüber
hinaus schickte der Kreml alle möglichen
Propaganda und reparationsprofis ist
Nachbarland um die Macht des Regimes zu
konsolidieren um euch das Ausmaß dieser
gewaltigen Infiltration eines ganzen
Landes zu verdeutlichen praktisch alle
belarussischen Fernsehkanäle wurden
damals von russischen Propagandisten
übernommen Propagandisten die ihre Noten
natürlich aus Moskau und nicht aus Minsk
erhielten der Punkt war das Lukaschenka
mit all dieser Hilfe und mit der
Garantie dass die russische Armee jede
Art von Aufstand gegen das Regime
niederschlagen würde die Unterdrückung
zur Verfolgung aller politischen
Oppositionen verstärken konnte ohne
aufgrund dessen Konsequenzen aus dem
Westen fürchten zu müssen er konnte bei
der Unterdrückung seiner Bevölkerung nun
so richtig Vollgas geben erinnert ihr
euch noch was im Jahr 2021 passiert ist
23 mai 2021 Ryanair bestätigt das
Weißrussland eines seiner Flugzeuge zur
Landung gezwungen hat genau die
weißrussische Luftwaffe Zwang eine
Ryanair-Maschine die zwischen Athen und
Vilnius flog zur Landung in Minz um
romansevic und seine Partnerin Sophia zu
verhaften prozessevic ist ein Journalist
und kritischer oppositionsaktivist der
in der Europäischen Union Asyl erhalten
hatte ja ein europäisches
Verkehrsflugzeug durch Kampfjets zu
zwingen zwischen 2 europäischen Städten
zu landen und das alles um eine Person
mit politischen Asyl in Europa zu
kidnappen das bedeutet natürlich dass
alle roten Linien überschritten wurden
aber wie gesagt damals konnte man sich
das in Gedanken der Unterstützung Moskau
einfach leisten Resultat ist jetzt wo
man einen Pakt mit dem geschlossen hatte
konnte man jegliche Zurückhaltung
aufgeben wir haben damals zum Beispiel
auch ein Video darüber gedreht wie Luca
schenka auf putinsgar heißt die
Europäische Union mit Migranten aus dem
Nahen Osten terrorisiert die er ins Land
einfliegen ließ um sie dann über die
Grenze nach Polen zu schicken ich werde
euch das Video verlinken natürlich darf
man aber einen wichtigen Haken an der
ganzen Geschichte nicht vergessen eine
packt mit dem Teufel ist nie kostenlos
er gibt eine Macht über andere aber am
Ende will der Teufel der alleinige
Herrscher sein und fordert seinen Preis
ein
[Musik]
das war eben auch hier der Fall im
Gegenzug für all diese Hilfe musste der
weißrussischen Diktator dem Kreml viel
mehr Einfluss als zuvor gewähren er
musste sich sogar verpflichten eine
Verfassungsreform durchzusetzen die zum
Beispiel die dauerhafte Stationierung
russischer Truppen im Land ermöglicht
wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt wurde
dieser ganze Prozess von vielen neuen
Sanktionen der internationalen
Gemeinschaft begleitet die die
Abhängigkeit des Landes von Russland
natürlich noch weiter vertieft haben ein
Teufelskreis sagen wir einfach dass die
Ära der Annäherung an den besten
endgültig zu Ende gegangen war zumindest
für dieses Regime und das war natürlich
auch der Punkt an dem alles kippte ihr
müsst nämlich verstehen dass ich weiß
Russland durchaus jahrelang mit zehn und
Klauen gegen die Eröffnung russischer
Militärstützpunkte im Land gewährt hat
in Minsk haben sie logischerweise
verstanden dass dies eine unerträgliche
Bedrohung darstellt welche bittere
Schicksal ein erwartet wenn man sich auf
russischen Schutz verlässt müssen
zurzeit auch die Armenier auf die harte
Tour erfahren dort droht möglicher Weise
der nächste genutzt direkt vor den Toren
Europas aber darüber werden wir in eine
separaten Video berichten vergesst also
bitte nicht das Abo unbedingt mit
Glöckchen um es nicht zu verpassen die
Ironie im Falle armenien ist natürlich
das ist als Demokratie durchaus mehr
Möglichkeiten hatte beim besten Schutz
zu suchen dies war bei minskradikator
anders er hatte nach seiner Errettung im
Jahr 2020 keine andere Wahl mehr als den
russischen Forderungen nachzugeben
so wurde neben den Wachstum
militärischen Beziehungen ab 2020 vom
Lukaschenko Regime auch eine starke
anti-westliche Rhetorik aufgefahren und
das Thema der Union zwischen Russland
und Belarus kehrte auf die Titelseiten
zurück wie gesagt hat er 2021 10.000
Migranten aus dem Nahen Osten und Afrika
missbraucht um eine politische und
humanitäre Krise an der Grenze zu Polen
und Litauen auszulösen und im November
desselben Jahres erkannte mindestens zum
ersten Mal die Grimm als Teil Russlands
an ihr seht dieses timing ist alles
andere als ein Zufall und es ist auch
klar wer hier die Fäden Zug aber es kam
noch schlimmer denn außerdem wurde im
ganzen Land ein intensives
rossifizierungsprogramm eingeleitet
sogar heißt historisches Skulpturen der
Herrschaft des Großfürstentums Litauen
wurden aus der Nationalmuseum entfernt
alle Erinnerungen an die mehr als sechs
Jahrhunderte der Bindungen andere
Staaten im Westen wurden aus dem
öffentlichen Raum eliminiert von diesen
Zeitpunkt an durfte die Vergangenheit
Weißrussland nur noch offiziell durch
Russland führen
[Musik]
aber aufgepasst es sind nicht nur
politische Faktoren die Beziehungen zum
Rest der Welt und Fragen der kulturellen
Identität die die Unabhängigkeit von
Belarus gefährden die Wahrheit ist dass
dieses Land auf allen Ebenen immer
stärker mit Russland verflochten ist in
der Tat ist es mittlerweile sogar extrem
schwierig geworden zu behaupten es würde
sich noch immer um ein unabhängiges Land
Handeln wollt ihr genau wissen wovon ich
ihr spreche nun hört jetzt gut zu
[Musik]
einem feindliches Übernahmeangebot
meine Lieben Zuschauer der russische
Überfall auf die Ukraine hat
Weißrussland zu einem pariatstadt
gemacht und das Land auf den
internationalen Märkten völlig an den
Rand gedrängt die internationale
Gemeinschaft hat praktisch die gleichen
Sanktion verhängt wie gegen Russland mit
einem großen Unterschied dieses Land
verfügt weder über Öl noch Gas noch
nukleare Rohstoffe oder Technologie mit
denen es auf dem globalen geopolitischen
schachbrettspielen könnte wir haben in
einem früheren Video darüber berichtet
wie abhängig der Westen zum Beispiel
noch immer von herausatom ist und ich
werde es euch verlinken allerdings läuft
der Hase im Falle von Bella raus ganz
anders das Land hat nichts womit es auch
internationale Ebene auftrumpfen könnte
und das erklärt warum die Sanktion hier
viel verheerende wirken als in Russland
selbst so brachen allein in den ersten
Monaten des Krieges die belarussischen
Exporte in die Europäische Union und
fast 60% einige der florianischen
Unternehmen verließen das Land die
Industrie musste mehr als 15% ihrer
Beschäftigten entlassen die Löhne in
funktionierten Sektoren sankten
drastisch und die Wirtschaft insgesamt
viel im Jahr 2022 um fünf Prozent und
das ist eine optimistische Schätzung und
natürlich wie wir euch bereits gesagt
haben es weist Russland heute viel
abhängiger von Russland als je zuvor
aber die Frage die wir uns jetzt stellen
müssen lautet wie weit diese
Abhängigkeit wirklich geht
nun wollt ihr die Wahrheit hören sie ist
fast vollständig die Abhängigkeit
Weißrussland von Russland ist so
umfangreich dass eine der wichtigsten
öffentlichen Einnahmequellen des Landes
darin besteht einen Teil des Öls das ist
zu subventionierten Preisen aus Russland
erhält auf den internationalen Markt
weiter zu verkaufen schätzungen zufolge
konnte Minsk im Jahr 2022 ein Profit von
1,7 Milliarden Dollar allein aus diesem
Geschäft einstreichen im Jahr 2023
werden es voraussichtlich fast 3
Milliarden Dollar sein offensichtlich
weiß man im Kreml über diese Operation
Bescheid und rate mal letztendlich ist
es ihnen egal im Gegenteil in Russen ist
jede Gelegenheit recht mit der sie ihr
Blut öllos werden können schließlich
sind nun sogar die als Rettungsanker
gepriesenen Exporte nach Indien
drastisch eingebrochen da sich auch die
Inder nicht zu abhängig machen wollen
von russischen Öl schließlich hat der
Creme schon mehr als oft klar gemacht
wozu er in der Lage ist wenn er die
Kontrolle über den energiehahn eines
Landes in seiner gesund hält für Belarus
freilich ist dieser Erkenntnis nutzlos
zu den hauptexportgütern des Landes
zählen vor allem Kraftstoffe die aus
russischem Öl hergestellt werden das
auch noch jahrelang von Moskau
subventioniert wurde es waren für den
Kreml verdammt gut angelegtes
Subventionen denn wie könnte man ein
Land besser unter seine Kontrolle
bringen als dass sein wichtigster
Wirtschaftszweig ausschließlich von
einem selbst abhängt und dabei geht es
nicht einmal nur um das Öl das ist
weiterverkauft oder die raffinierten
Kraftstoffe die ist exportiert insgesamt
kommen mehr als zwei Drittel der Energie
die das Land verbraucht entweder aus
Russland oder werden von russischen
Unternehmen kontrolliert mit anderen
Worten wenn Moskau den Haaren zudreht
sitzt Weißrussland praktisch im Dunkeln
und in der Kälte der Kollaps des ganzen
Landes wäre unabwendbar das nennt man
absolute Abhängigkeit aber so
unglaublich dies auch klingen mag die
Energieabhängigkeit bildet hier nur die
Spitze des Eisbergs etwa die Hälfte
aller ausschulden des Landes befindet
sich in russischer Hand bei den
ausländischen Direktinvestitionen sieht
es ähnlich aus und zu allem Überfluss
kontrollieren viele russische
Staatsunternehmen wichtige
Vermögenswerte in Belarus wir sprechen
von Banken Telekommunikationsunternehmen
und sogar den Raffinerien man fragt sich
was in diesem Land eigentlich noch den
weißrösten selbst gehört aber wartet es
wird noch schlimmer es wird geschätzt
dass heute 60 bis 70% aller
belarussischen Exporte in das Land
Wladimir Putins gehen mit anderen Worten
aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht können wir
nicht mehr von einem unabhängigen Land
sprechen volkswirtschaftlich ist Belarus
bereits eine Provinz oder Kolonie der
moskovita
und all das erklärt warum Russland als
es die Ukraine überfallen hat und kieff
in drei Tagen einnehmen wollte seinen
Nachbarstadt benutzen konnte wie es
wollte lukaschenker hatte keinerlei
Handhabe sich dagegen zu wehren
tatsächlich ist dieses Land seit Beginn
der Invasion eine der wichtigsten Basis
für raketenabschlüsse hat den russischen
Streitkräften einen großen Teil seiner
militärischen Arsenal zur Verfügung
gestellt Ihnen die intensive Nutzung
seine Eisenbahnen und Straßen erlaubt
und ist sogar zu einem der wichtigsten
medizinischen Versorgungszentren für an
der Front verwundete russische Soldaten
[Musik]
okay werdet jetzt sagen das ist doch
nichts Neues warum sagen wir dann das
ausgerechnet die jetzt eine reale Gefahr
der Annexion durch Russland besteht nun
ganz einfach weil der Krieg in der
Ukraine für Russland alles andere als
glorreich verläuft und dann könnte
ausgerechnet Weißrussland am Ende eine
Art Trostpreis darstellen denn was auch
immer in diesem Krieg noch passieren
wird es ist klar dass Putin Feldzug ein
durchschlagender Misserfolg war ist und
sein wird und natürlich präsentiert sich
kein töran gerne als besiegter als Loser
Putin hat versprochen Russland zu
schützen und größer zu machen aber in
der Ukraine wird in das nie und nimmer
gelingen im Gegenteil ja Jahre lang hat
Weißrussland versucht zu jonglieren die
Vorteile des russischen Bären zu nutzen
ohne ganz in dessen Fänge zu geraten
jetzt scheint dies nicht mehr möglich zu
sein Putin weißt das und wird
keinerleist Kumpel haben die Notlage
Weißrusslands für sich und seine
Propaganda auszunutzen eine Möglichkeit
wäre einen Anschluss an Russland im
Rahmen des unionsstaats oder einer
anderen politischen Erfindung zu
erzwingen zum Beispiel die
Wiederherstellung der Satellitenstaaten
der ehemaligen Sowjetunion auf diese
Weise könnte er sein Anhängern das Bild
eines größeren und stärkeren Russlands
verkaufen es wäre immerhin ein Erfolg im
Rahmen einer gewaltigen politischen
wirtschaftlichen und militärischen
Niederlage tja wie schön wäre es wenn
man all die bittere Schmach mit
feierlichen Pump und lobesenden über die
Vollendung der lang ersehnten Union über
München und übertönen könnte schließlich
geht es der klicke die den Kreml
momentan besetzt hätten nur um eines
ihren eigenen macht er halt um jeden
Preis und aus dieser Perspektive wäre
ein Annexion Weißrusslands kein
schlechter Schachzug findet ihr nicht
[Musik]
meine Lieben Zuschauer alle Anzeichen
deuten daraufhin das Weißrussland auf
die eine oder andere Weise kurz davor
steht seines Souveränität zu verlieren
wenn es sie nicht schon verloren hat der
versucht die Wagner Söldener einzuheben
und zu beherbergen war vielleicht Lukas
schenkas letzter Strohhalm um sich mehr
Handlungsspielraum zu sichern aber mit
dem Abschluss bringens ist auch das nun
Geschichte je stärker und je schneller
Russland in der Ukraine verliert und
zurückgedrängt wird desto
wahrscheinlicher wird es das
Weißrussland einfach von der Landkarte
verschwindet das Schicksal der Ukrainer
und weiß Rosen scheint sich wie auf
genau entgegengesetzten Waagschalen zu
bewegen die Frage ist daher wird mit
einem Sieg der Ukraine die Existenz
Weißrusslands zu Ende gehen nun noch
wissen will nicht wie diese Sieg
aussehen wird Lukaschenka könnte mal
wieder mehr Glück als Verstand haben
vielleicht könnten sich die Dinge für
den Bauern schlauen gemacht habe auch
diesmal wieder wenden was würde zum
Beispiel geschehen Putin stirbt was wenn
die Niederlage Russland so dramatisch
ausfällt dass sie einen Domino-Effekt
auslöst all das sind Szenarien die
durchaus in Frage kommen und deswegen
werden wir für euch am Ball bleiben
vergesst also bitte nicht unseren Kanal
zu abonnieren wenn dies nicht schon der
Fall sein sollte und bis zum nächsten
Video sind die Fragen erstmal wieder an
euch gerichtet glaubt ihr das Russland
Weißrussland endgültig annektieren und
zu einem völlig untergeordneten Staat
machen wird oder werden Lukas Schenker
und seine Minsker Handlanger ihre Köpfe
doch noch irgendwie wieder aus der
Schlinge ziehen können wie sollte der
Westen mit dieser ganzen Geschichte
umgehen gibt es Wege Weißrussland wieder
näher zu kommen und den Fängen Putin zu
entreißen so wie es eigentlich mit der
Ukraine ja auch gelungen ist wie immer
sind auf eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns Freunden und
diskutiert es mit ihnen natürlich freuen
uns auch jederzeit über eine Spende von
euch mit diesem Projekt weiterzuführen
den Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video macht's gut
und bis bald
[Musik]